foreign
[Music]
is not only a beautiful Jersey but it
sounds a fantastic message from Bohemian
football club in Ireland that the people
here are fully behind the struggle that
is going on in Palestine
[Music]
good
it's obviously taken inspiration from
the Palestinian flag in terms of the
colors the dove on the back of the tag
the sport is something that's played
everywhere and football in particular is
played in every country in the world so
we could assist this charity to help and
you know brighten up the days of
children who are in really difficult
circumstances and then it's an obvious
thing for us to do
[Music]
in Ireland here we were victims of
colonialism in the country and there was
you know maybe some kind of shared
experience there it's something that I
think people feel solidarity with well I
come from Derry uh Dairy has been a
place that has had its own conflict is a
is a place in Ireland that has seen its
fair share of war and trouble and
looking at the pain that the young
people in Palestine are feeling as I say
if we can help in any little way this
club will be here to help
thank you
if we can put money back under the sport
and Palestine to help you on players and
young people through the medium of sport
and football especially then we are
delighted to do that foreign